hello everyone I'm extremely sorry about
my long term of absence over the last
month's but suffice to say the reason
for my absence is the reason why I don't
but enough of me may SCP we're going to
be looking at today is SCP 174 object
class safe no sorry I read that wrong
Euclid C incident 174 a-ok so well we'll
get to that special containment
procedures as CP 174 is to be contained
within storage unit 0 7 at site 19
removal of scp-172 4 from containment
requires their approval of 2 level 4
personnel familiar with the entity it is
preferable to use personnel with high
psychic resistance scale scores when
interacting with a CP 174 all personnel
in contact with SCP 174 are to undergo
psychological evaluation those who
display obsessive or protective
tendencies toward the item are to be
treated with class PM easy acts and
monitored for 72 hours underneath this
is an addendum to the containment
procedures on this
[Music]
following incident 174 a SCP 174 and the
main chamber of storage unit 7 are to be
monitored at all times via video
surveillance abnormal activity must be
reported to doctor immediately
furthermore a GPS tracking devices to be
installed on SCP 174 in order to
expedite recovery should the item
translocate outside of foundation
custody description SCP 174 is a wooden
ventriloquism 21 centimeters from head
to toe with somewhat ragged clothing and
slight damage to several sections
judging by the items style and state of
repair it dates from the early 20th
century the eyes and mouth of scp-172 4
could be manipulated by means of a
mechanism inside the figure when viewed
in peripheral
subjects report on occasion that SCP 174
is looking directly at them with an
expression of longing or sadness when
subjects look directly at the CP 174
this anomalous expression is not visible
viewing SCP 174 indirectly
such as in a mirror or a live video feed
appears to increase the likelihood of
this effect manifesting itself personnel
in the vicinity of scp-172 for report a
general feeling of sadness or sympathy
directed towards the figure but cannot
explain any reason for these feelings
prolonged exposure can lead to personnel
personifying the figure to greater
extents those with particularly low
psychic resistance scale scores well in
some cases begin to act as if a CP 174
were a living being
for example cradling Ennis if it were a
baby
when informed of their abnormal behavior
all personnel revert to standard
behavior patterns for at least several
minutes subjects who place SCP 174 on
their hand report an urge to converse
with it when questioned they frequently
report that the figure is lonely and
needs companionship the subject will
also begin speaking for SCP 174 and
manipulating its expression when
speaking for the figure the subjects
voice will take on a higher-pitched
childlike tone recordings taken with
high sensitivity microphones have
determined that and no point does the
figure itself actually speak or make any
discernible noise regardless of the
subject experience act will be almost
perfect the conversation will quickly
move towards the discussion of the
figures emotional state particularly in
relation to its past in most cases
leading to the retelling by the figure
of a story of how it was abandoned or
mistreated no one story has ever been
repeated and therefore which if any is
true is unknown researchers have
theorized that a CP 174 may have
low-level telepath
abilities as each story seems to be
based around a theme that will have a
particular resonance with the current
subject past this point
subjects will show great affection for a
CPU 174 and will attempt to protect it
from people who come too close or try to
interact with it in some cases with
deadly force subjects often refer to a
CP 174 as their quote baby or you
similarly strong terms of endearment
when referring to it this effect
persists for several hours after s CP
174 and the subject have been separated
and in at least one case the effect had
not dissipated two weeks
after final interaction whether the
effect could have ever lessened is
unknown as the subject in question was
terminated owing to lack of a compelling
reason for further study subjects who
are completely isolated from scp-172 4
will become paranoid as to the figures
safety and often undergo a mental
collapse similar to that observed in
mothers separated from young children
Class B are stronger amnesiacs have been
shown to be effective in curing both the
obsessive affect in the majority of any
resultant mental trauma however almost
all who undergo such treatment complain
of feelings of loss and can become
depressive this is addendum 174 - one
experiment log transcription of video
footage subject d1 4 - 8 5 female 21 no
history of violent crime supervising
researcher dr. location containment cell
a4 researcher and staff observing from
behind a two-way mirror
in site 19 D 1 4 - 8 5 is ordered to
place a CP 174 on their hand the subject
does so after initial hesitation after
several seconds the subject begins a
mundane conversation with SCP 174 after
2 minutes the subject asks SCP 174 what
happened
at which point the figure begins to
recount the story of how it was left
behind damaged in a house fire and
subsequently discarded by its original
owner note subjects records indicate
that her house was the victim of an
arson attack in 1930 subject begins to
console the figure and reassure it with
standard positive statements figure
remarks that is lonely and it wants to
find friends subject begins to punch
should pound the door with their free
hand when guards enter the sell-side
arms raised subject recoils into the
corner of the cell cradling the figure
and whispering to it exact words not
picked up by the microphone dart
succeeded in removing SCP 174 from the
subject and leave the cell at this point
the subject screams they have him my
wonderful baby and begins punching
kicking the door in a futile escape
attempt note at this point doctor
ordered the experiment concluded d14 285
was terminated after attempts to calm
her failed this experiment was one of
the first conducted with a CP 174 before
the efficacy of amnesiacs had become
apparent and finally this is addendum
174 - - incident 174 a odd doctor
entered storage unit 7 to find SCP 174
sitting on the floor next to its
containment unit looking directly at the
main entrance door the door to SCP 174 s
unit had been sealed shut with null
access but logged in the previous week
after being replaced in containment
video surveillance was installed within
storage unit 7 as a precaution against
future translocations and a GPS tracking
unit was attached to a CPU on 74
oh well I hope I never get to meet that
skipper after the month I've had I want
a desk job
[Music]
you
[Music]